Are you one of those people who
hate these little crawling things?
Or maybe these ones with
stingers creep you out more?
Have you ever wished that all
the insects would just die out?
Picnics would be much more pleasant.
And so would gardening.
This is WHAT IF,
and here's what would happen
if all insects disappeared from the planet.
If you think bugs only
exist to give you the creeps
and to chew on the lettuce
in your garden, you're wrong.
Well, not totally wrong.
Some of them are, in fact,
meant to destroy crops,
give you skin irritations in
addition to painful stings,
and even worse - spread
diseases like Zika and malaria.
But 90% of them are not only harmless,
but beneficial to us, and to the planet.
They say, without insects,
the world would fall apart.
If we put all the insects on
the planet together on a scale,
they would weigh approximately 300
times more than all humans combined.
If you have insectophobia, you
probably want me to stop right here.
Just let me add that, the ants alone
would weigh more than all humans.
If our planet suddenly had all
this weight off its shoulders,
farmers would be the first to celebrate.
They'd no longer need to
pour chemicals on their crops
to save the harvest from hungry pests.
But that celebration wouldn't last long.
Because without insects,
we'd all starve pretty fast.
And no, we don't mean those bold adventurers,
who snack on crickets and grasshoppers
somewhere in Thailand, would starve.
Humans might be predators in the food chain,
but insects are the ones
to hold this chain together.
They are food for some
reptiles, small birds and frogs.
If all the insects vanished, those
animals would cease to exist, too.
The animals feeding on frogs and
reptiles would be the next to die off.
And then the ones further up the chain.
Eventually, this disruption would
work its way up to humans.
Think you could survive by going vegan?
Wrong again.
80% of all the plant life on the planet
is made up of flowering plants,
meaning they require pollination to reproduce.
Insects are the ones who make this happen,
by physically transferring pollen from
a male anther to a female stigma.
You can argue that birds and bats,
even wind can pollinate, too,
but most of the work is done by bees,
wasps, moths, butterflies and flies.
Without them, it's 'game-over' for most plants.
Depending on what your food preferences are,
50 to 90% of your diet comes
from those flowering plants.
There would be no fruit, no
vegetables, no rice and no wheat.
This also means no food for cows,
chickens, most freshwater fish,
and all the animals we, humans, eat.
It doesn't matter if you're
a vegetarian or a meat-lover -
if the insects disappeared, you'd
have no chance of long-term survival.
You'd be left to slowly starve on a planet
heaped up with piles of organic waste.
Because not only do insects feed
small animals and pollinate plants,
they're also major decomposers of dead stuff -
from leaves to corpses.
That wouldn't be the world you'd want to leave in.
And to be honest, not all all
the insects are gross-looking,
wouldn't you agree?
Join us next time on WHAT IF.